I went on your uh wedding website
yesterday but that's quite a website
you've got going on there not me that's
on my website Robin have you been on
that yet no
if you if you don't get enough Ronnie on
the invitation you can go to a website
and see a whole gallery of pictures of
him with Stephanie I can't wait to see
that what with all the pictures intimate
pictures I have no idea you have to talk
to Stephanie about that interview her
about it why do you got cursing all over
the website too with what what's with
you in the word dick hole what is that
that's her that's her what's that that's
her nickname for me okay but why does
she put dick hole on there ask her why
are you breaking my balls about you
asked her did you say it or what the
[__] no I didn't say anything listen I'm
not trying to bust balls here I'm just
trying to tell you
okay JD and I were going through every
single tab on the website reading
through taking notes it's great oh great
that's so cool man Ronnie I'm telling
you
it's so cool that you're taking [__]
notes it's terrific
by the way Ron what does it mean I have
to Dr dress to impress dress to impress
and cocktail attires boy oh boy oh boy
JD what are you gonna wear when you
readjust to impress what does that mean
that's when I when I read cocktail
attire I thought does that mean we don't
have to wear a suit does that mean I can
wear like just a button shirt and uh you
know jeans or something if I want right
yeah so but then I I think it does mean
like some sort of suit it's the wrong
thing to send to this crowd
I like it when you go to things if you
go to things to do it says it's Las
Vegas do we really need to tell you what
to do
but Ron if you say things to do don't
put us down here and do it dude perfect
and wrong person I'm just trying to talk
to you man to man but you get so [__]
touchy because I don't I listen that's
her thing man let her do it it's fine
Ronnie it's your thing too that's no
[__] up no it's worth it Jason the
wedding is your thing it hurts it's
always what about your day that's so
[__] way man okay
you can't I mean the front page of the
website is Dick Hole Tavern what is dick
hole Tavern
if you go to there's a foot I don't know
asked questions of the website oh if you
go there which is very informative it
says what's the wedding hashtag they
don't want you to tag the location in
your pictures but you can put hashtag
the months or hashtag dick hole Tavern
what's up face